- Ces excuses étaient attendues
le refus de ses prédécesseurs,
le pape François a finalement
prononcé les mots historiques.
Il a écouté les témoignages
des survivants des pensionna
Lorsqu'est venu le temps de
prendre la parole, le chef de
l'Église catholique a fait plus
que de présenter ses excuses.
Il a dit toute la honte et
pensant aux rôles que plusieurs
congrégations catholiques
ont joués dans les pensionnats;
un traitement des enfants
autochtoenseignements de Jésus-,
dit le pape.
Pour continuer de faire
avancer le pape François réitèri
son engagement de venir bientôt
non seulement au Canada, mais
aussi en territoire autochtone.
Sa visôt qu'en juillet.
Marqués dans leur chair et
dans leur esprit, les survivants
et leursdroit au coeur
par les mots du Saint-Père.
MANDY GULL-MASTY, grande cheffe
Grand Conseil des Cris
- Aujourd'hui, c'eue
pour les Premières Nations,pour,
les Nations Inuit.sidente desidn
métisse n'oubliera jamais
le moment qu'elle a partagé avec
une survivante des pensionnats.
Les Autochtones se sont
face à l'Église qXÑZ
Aujourd'hui, c'est toute leur
humanité, longtemps ignorée,
grâce à ces excuses.
Si les mots du pape
agissent comme un
... les Autochtones soulignent
qu'il s'agit d'abord et
dans le  réconciliation.
Ils attendent encore que le pape
répète ces mots chez eux,
L'Église catholique canad
reconnaît qu'il reste du travail
à faire, mais souligne
Mgr RAYMOND POISSON, Conférence
évêques catholiques du Cana
- On va continuer dans
pour ce qui est du Saint-Père,
première grande atin.atin.atin..
- 150 000 enfants ont été
arrachés à leurs familles
les pensionnats et au moins
4000 y sont morts à cause
des mauvais traitements subis.
Si ces excuses historiques
ce lourd passé, elles permettent
de commencer à guérir
les profondes blessures qui
subsistent encore à ce jour.
anada, Rom